my channel is sponsored by raycon which
means we will hear more from them in the
middle of this video hey everyone i'm
alana and welcome to my channel where
today we are talking about
a post that ubisoft released that is
called the politics of far cry 6 and
essentially everything that led up to
them
needing to make that post or feeling
like they needed to make that post i've
been doing more of these videos lately i
did it with hot tub streamers i did it
with the ign deleted tweets
and the intent here is to give you guys
an accurate timeline that you may have
missed because i feel like a lot of this
conversation happens on twitter
okay so for anyone who somehow doesn't
know
i'm just going to talk about the setting
of far cry 6 a little bit
this is ubisoft's official far cry 6
page that says welcome to
yara embrace the gritty experience of an
improvised modern day gorilla and take
down a dictator and his son
to free yara release date etc this page
is actually really cool i'm going to
remove my webcam for you guys
so you've got this image here that when
you scroll
goes up in flames but where of the
dictator anton will even sacrifice his
own people to forge his paradise do not
trust him very cool and then there are
like these snippets of newspapers saying
guerrilla fighters destroy capital
which also features a quote over here of
the president saying
the guerrillas are a traitor to the
great country and then there's a
separate take here saying guerilla
fighters defend freedom
we fight to liberate our nation from the
oppression of a ruthless tyrant giving
you basically both perspectives
on uh capital being destroyed and i just
wanted to show you guys this because i
feel like
it is even though i'm ruining it with my
bad display capture just a very good
indication of what the game is about it
is
political in nature you are overthrowing
in government
it is clearly telling you that the
president is
sharing something that is different to
what the common people think
in terms of how this whole thing has
gone down there's indications of
propaganda
that's not to say it's taking one
political side or another we don't
actually know the political climate of
this place
it's not left-wing or right-wing but it
is a political setting so the game was
revealed as part of a presentation that
ubisoft had
last week and a number of interviews
released afterwards
um which i will get to but the way that
i first found out about this entire
discourse was a number of tweets that
look a lot like this ubisoft maintains
non-political stance with far cry 6
a game about a political uprising there
were tweets saying ubisoft claims far
cry 6 is not political
ubisoft avoiding politics with far cry 6
generally things saying
ubisoft is not making far cry political
and my reaction to seeing that small
snippet before i dug into this photo was
essentially
that's ridiculous it's okay for them to
say that
but it is objectively not true
and you have to remember political
doesn't necessarily mean something in
his left wing or right wing it is a game
about a political uprising it doesn't
mean it has any allegiance
which is i feel like what confuses a lot
of this discourse is when people say
they don't want politics and games they
are generally referring to left-wing
politics
in some cases right-wing politics but
political as a theme is kind of
unavoidable but i would say now having
more context
that uh that was taken out of context
this was the actual original story which
is from the gamer.com that says ubisoft
doesn't want to make a political
statement specifically about
cuba with far cry 6. i feel like they
probably updated that
headline but they were specifically
talking about not making any kind of
commentary on cuba
even though the story is pretty clearly
inspired by
cuba i won't get into those comparisons
i do not know enough about the situation
in cuba to give you the right
information about that someone else
could do a much better job than i could
but yes i can
definitively say the game is clearly
inspired by the situation in cuba uh it
does say here that they updated their
headlines so this says the headline has
been changed after speaking
ubisoft who acknowledges the game is
inherently political but stresses that
the game isn't a comment on
cuba specifically so that's why that
reads like such a strange headline get
out of here far cry ad god
that's that's some that's some marketing
at work that's google
just get out of here google just leave
me just just leave me alone the original
story said ubisoft is keen to express a
true gorilla fantasy with far cry 6
having spoken to actual freedom fighters
about the act of taking part in a
revolution
despite this it wants to avoid making a
political statement with the upcoming
open world
shooter which again people kind of
translated to they spoke to actual
guerrilla fighters but they're not
making a political game
what they go on to say speaking to the
gamer narrative director naveed kavari
talked to us about the island of yara
and the circumstances behind its
inevitable arrival of a revolution
he wanted to pay homage to fighters from
the past while also crafting a narrative
that wishes to avoid drawing on
inspiration from similar events found in
reality the original inspiration was
guerrilla warfare and what is that
gorilla fantasy which is obviously tied
to revolution
when you talk about gorillas you think
of the gorillas in the 1950s and the
1960s
we actually went down there to speak to
actual gorilla fighters who fought back
then and we just really fell in love
with their stories
kavari tells us but we also fell in love
with the culture and people we met
when we came out of that it wasn't that
we felt we had to do cuba
we realized it's a complicated island
and our game doesn't want to make a
political statement about what's
happening in cuba specifically
for us it felt like doing the island of
yara would help us tell that story while
being very open with our politics
and inspiration uh the article goes on
to say this part is not a quote
although it seemingly attempts to
disassociate from political themes far
cry 6 still intends to tell an engaging
story and one that isn't afraid to
explore the deeper circumstances of a
revolution a revolution is complex and
the people you're
going to engage with are also complex i
use this line of philosophy which is
that every character has their own
heartbeat you just have to find it
kobari says who also wants the game to
strike a balance between serious
storytelling and engaging action we have
this melting pot of motivational
complexity where we tried to translate
that into the gameplay and the story so
tonally it sort of already existed but
for us thematically unifying that into
gorilla fantasy felt pretty natural so
that's basically where this all
kind of started was a misunderstanding
of a quote
now is a good time for us to talk about
raycon
raycon is disrupting the electronics
industry by making great
sound for everyone their wireless
earbuds start at half the price of other
premium audio brands
give you six hours of playtime seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass and a more
compact design for a comfortable noise
isolating fit the design really is one
of my favorite things about it it's
really small
it's really comfortable it's really
lightweight and i feel like also very
subtle they're not obnoxious they don't
have dangly bits
plus they do also come in a range of fun
colors and patterns with a variety of
fit options
and like i said no stems or wires and
naturally
they've been great for me in this one
hotel room that i've not been able to
leave for the last several weeks
i've used them on meetings at my
computer going to you know maybe
cleaning up the room going to work out
in my oculus
and sometimes even while head banging
and it is one of my favorite things is
that they don't even move when you do a
shake test it's amazing
and they also just in case you guys
didn't know have a 45 day free
return policy which we love so click the
link in the description box or go to buy
recon dot com slash alana to get 15
off your recon purchase so ubisoft
published this saying the politics of
far cry 6. this is on june 1st
and this was written by that same
narrative director it says
our story is political a story about a
modern revolution must be
there are hard relevant discussions in
far cry 6 about the conditions that led
to the rise of fascism in a nation
the cost of imperialism forced labor the
need for free and fair elections
lgbtq plus rights and more within the
context of yara a fictional island in
the caribbean my goal was to empower our
team to be fearless in the story we were
telling and we worked incredibly hard to
do this over the last five years
we also tried to be very careful about
how we approached our inspirations which
include cuba
but also other countries around the
world that have experienced political
revolutions in their history
in our approach we made sure to see
creators and collaborators for our team
who can speak personally to the history
and cultures of the region we were
inspired by
we also brought on experts and
consultants to examine the game story
multiple times over the course of the
project to make sure it was being told
with sensitivity
it is not for me to decide if we
succeeded but i can absolutely say that
we tried
but i can say we absolutely tried my
brain just muddled those words the
conversations and research done on the
perspectives of those who fought
revolutions in the late 1950s early
1960s and beyond
absolutely reflected in our story and
characters but if anyone is seeking a
simplified binary political statement
specifically on the current
political climate in cuba they won't
find it i'm from a family that has
endured the consequences of revolution i
have debated revolution over the dinner
table my entire life i can only speak
for myself but it is a
but it is a complex subject that should
never be boiled down to one quote what
players will find is a story that's
point of view attempts to capture the
political complexity of a modern present
day revolution within a fictional
context
we have attempted to tell a story with
action adventure and heart but that also
isn't afraid to ask hard questions
vakara is a brand that in its dna seeks
to have mature complex themes balanced
with levity and humor
one doesn't exist without the other and
we have attempted to achieve this
balance with care my only hope is that
we are willing to let the story speak
for itself before forming hard opinions
on its political reflections
thank you for reading signed off navid
khabari narrative director farcry6
and this all makes how is my webcam
moving down how does my head keep
getting cut off it probably is slowly
moving and i'm not realizing it
i don't think i'm moving i don't know so
that all makes sense to me
um it is essentially saying of course
the game's political we're just trying
not to speak about cuba
specifically and i totally feel like
that is a fair and reasonable stance
that i think mostly catches people up
on this entire controversy i don't
really feel like it was very
controversial
discourse discussion but it does also
come off of the back of some criticism
that far cry 5
had a weaker story because it didn't
commit to its politics
and i definitely do think that that can
happen in media if someone
toes the line with something that is uh
political but then backs off
in fear of offending people or upsetting
people i think that you can end up with
a really bland
story i'm not saying that i think far
cry 5 did that i actually didn't end up
finishing far cry 5
played an amount of it but didn't finish
it but far cry has kind of danced around
this stuff for quite some time
suggesting
that games are not political when they
absolutely are i mean assassin's creed
is
absolutely political assassin's creed 2
is so
thematically political it seems so silly
to even try to deny it it's also that if
they were even trying to not write them
politically it'd be very hard to do i
think it's difficult to have a story
about you overthrowing
you know religious figureheads and be
like well but
uh let's avoid the political themes make
sure you delete that reference of
corruption again a political theme it
would be very limiting and i think the
stories would be a lot less interesting
if people were actually
trying to just say we don't have any
politics at all
i think it's just become part of the
language it's it's people kind of
associate you saying yes the game is
political like
for example bioshock an extremely
political game
extremely political in theme metal gear
solid extremely political
but it's difficult now to say yeah of
course we have political themes without
people
um taking that to mean i think like i
said generally
liberal politics and you know personal
opinion i do hope that we can get away
from that discourse
some of the best forms of entertainment
media and the most respected ones
do explore uncomfortable political
themes video games should be able to do
that too
and in the conversation that shouldn't
directly translate to shoehorning
politics pushing an agenda it should
just be
very serious themes that affect a lot of
people which is what politics are
so yeah i don't think i really have
anything else to add here i feel like
that gets you all
pretty much caught up on uh just the
discourse in case you missed it
i don't even feel like this one is is
terribly interesting overall other than
potentially the realization that
yes ubisoft all of your games have even
the smallest amount of
political context dealing with this
dictator
and uh these different versions of
propaganda
is it clearly political and i just kind
of hope that we can get to a point where
um
maybe you know even the use of the word
politics doesn't become
a buzzword where someone has to be like
yes obviously it's a dictatorship
obviously that's political
it is so unavoidable that it feels
redundant to have to talk about it and i
think even attempting to have absolutely
nothing political in a game like far cry
5 where it is guerrilla warfare
would just be impossible and you would
end up with a really weird story
it'd be really bizarre but that is it
for me today everyone i hope you feel
caught up
thank you again to rakon for sponsoring
the channel and
i will see you guys next time bye